I'm here at the joint Institute for nuclear research in Dubliner
in Russia,
the place where so many of the super heavy elements
have been created.
And I'm going to show you an absolutely key component for making
those elements.
And it's also probably the most expensive compound you've ever seen.
And the sample and get to show you is here on the table.
In many of our videos about these heavy elements,
we've talked about accelerating a light element onto a
target and creating the super-heavy elements,
but we've usually wrote the dismissed what the light element is.
We've said, well, it's calcium plus elements,
calcium 2020 plus ninety-five makes
115.
It is actually a very special [inaudible] isotope of calcium called
calcium 48. It occurs naturally,
but in a very, very small abundance.
So it has to be separated from the other isotopes,
the other atoms of calcium,
and because calcium doesn't have any compounds that the
gaseous, it literally has to be separated atom by atom in the
large magnetic separator. And so it is very expensive.
So here we have calcium carbonate,
but which just contains calcium 48.
It's so valuable. And my hand shakes so much,
I'm not allowed to touch it. But here with this pen,
you can see the approximate scale.
There are two grams of calcium carbonate here, which have worth,
or at least if you wanted to buy,
it would cost you about half a million dollars.
This is $250 for a milligram milligrams.
About the smallest amounts you can see easily. You're paying for the calcium,
the carbon dioxide and oxygen can free. All things come with a bonus.
When you buy them in the supermarket. If you buy calcium 48,
you get the company free.
The reason why it is so expensive is because you have to
produce ions of calcium by heating it to very,
very high temperature and then separating it in a high
vacuum, under a magnetic field.
And so you need a very big piece of operators with huge.
Electromagnets using a vast amount of electricity.
And apparently the industrial scale production of this material is
10 grams year.
So they produce about five times as much as you can see in this
bottle in a year,
this isotope is only used in nuclear physics.
And most of it is used for synthesizing super-heavy elements.
It is only made in one place in the world.
The so-called,
the electric combine electric convene that which is in a town called
[inaudible]
, which is about 200 kilometers North of the big city Katrine book in the Euro
mountains. So there's a monopoly supplier, but if you want to make money making calcium 48 is probably not the market
that you should go in for, because there's so few custom.
You can't use calcium carbonate.
In the accelerators. You need to use calcium metal.
There is some quite interesting and simple stage chemistry.
First of all, you heat the calcium carbonate to drive off the carbon dioxide.
The second stage involves a variation of
the so-called thermite reaction, which we have shown you.
Before.
You mix the calcium oxide with Allie minium powder
and heat them up.
And the aluminum powder reacts with the oxygen because it has a
stronger affinity for the oxygen and the calcium, the calcium metal,
this tiny sample or sample of calcium 48 is then put
into the iron source of the cyclotron.
This is where they make the calcium ions.
The iron source then generates calcium ions,
which are accelerated up to about a 10th of the speed of light and smashed into
the target.
The operators runs at a rate of about one
milligram of calcium 48 per hour.
So here we have two grams of calcium
carbonate,
which is probably one and a half grams of calcium
metal, or perhaps a little less.
So this is enough to run for more than a thousand hours of
cyclotron time,
but you can see what this sort of price it's an expensive experiment,
but the other cost of running the cyclotron are also large.
So even if you've spent half a million dollars on buying this,
you still have to spend some more money to start synthesizing your
super heavy elements.
You might ask yourself what is special about calcium 48,
that people go to all this trouble,
whereas they could get tons of the cheaper calcium for the same price.
The answer is that calcium 48 has the
largest excess of neutrons.
Calcium is atomic number 20. So it has 20 protons.
And because it's 48, it has 28 neutrons.
When you're making a super heavy element,
the more nutrients you can get into the final
nucleus of the heavy element,
the more likely it is to be stable by and large,
the number of neutrons in the target nucleus is fixed.
So you want to choose the light element,
the project projectile to be containing as many nutrients
as possible.
Now you don't have much choice because the identity of the elements is
dictated by the number of protons. If you want to add 20 to the,
to your atomic number of your target, you have to use calcium.
So you want the calcium isotope that has the most neutrons and the
number of neutrons and number of protons in calcium, uh,
both so-called magic numbers for particularly stable nucleus.
So 28 is a magic number for neutrons 24
protons.
So calcium 48 is a double magic nucleus.
You can't get better than that.
And when you bang the projectile into the target,
if the two nuclides fuse together,
then the nucleus still has a lot of energy and it loses
part of that energy as neutrons coming out.
And because you've got lots of neutrons,
you'll still have plenty left in the final nucleus and
calcium 48 has been the absolute key to the success
of the sentences of these super heavy elements in Duke now,
which is why they are the principle customer for the production
of the calcium 48.
The problem is for future synthesis of elements,
is that the highest atomic number of any target that has been
successfully used so far is 98, California.
So you can see just words relevant, 118 calcium,
20 California, 98, put them together.
You get 118,
but if you want like 119 or 120,
you've got to go to a heavier projectile.
The scientists working here looking at titanium 50,
but to attain him 50 is not as good as calcium 48.
It doesn't have a magic number.
So they're going to have to build a much more sensitive operators.
If they have any chance of success in detecting the new elements,
doesn't stick and you go on throwing and throwing more and
more. And eventually after days,
perhaps they stick together and you make a big
item.